welcome to the third part of my tutorial
on how to solve a 5x5 Rubik's Cube
professor at this point all of your
centers should be complete in this part
three I'm going to teach you how to pair
up two edges at a time the final part
four will cover how to correct the
parity errors which occur after we have
paired the edge pieces we must find an
outer edge piece and an inner edge piece
which are identical once you have found
two so here I have an outer blue/white
edge piece on the left side and here I
have an inner blue-white edge piece on
the right side the two edges must be
directly opposite each other and also
have switched orientations meaning that
this one has blue on the front and white
on the side while the other one has
white on the front and blue on the side
I like to bring the one on the inside up
layer over to the one on the middle
layer in order to realign the center's
we must replace this newly matched pair
with an unmatched pair so before I match
them up I make sure that there is an
unmatched pair in the top layer here
directly in front of the middle layer
edge piece okay so to match these two up
I'm going to bring the one on the inside
up layer over to the one on the middle
layer now what we have to do is get this
out of the way so that we can replace it
with a non matched pair so because the
newly matched pair is now on the right
side I need to bring the right face
clockwise or up so that this newly
matched pair is now on the top layer I
then turn the top face clockwise to
bring that newly matched pair directly
in front and then I'm going to bring the
right face counterclockwise or back down
this is that newly matched pair which I
originally showed you was over here and
now we can realign the center's without
worrying about breaking these two up
okay so now you'll see we have one newly
matched pair so now what you do is you
look around the cube for other pieces
which we can match up as you'll see I
have a red white outer edge piece here
and I have a red white middle edge piece
here what I need to do this one is in
the middle layer so I need to get this
one in the inside up layer so I'm going
to twist it here and then bring it
and as you'll notice they do have
opposite orientations because this
middle-aged piece is now on the left
side I need to make sure that I have an
unmatched pair here as you'll see these
two pieces are not matched properly so
it's okay if we split them up what I'm
going to do is bring this piece over to
the piece on the middle leg layer now
because the newly matched pair is on the
left side I'm going to bring the left
face counterclockwise bring the top face
counterclockwise so now you should see
that newly matched pair directly in
front and then I'm going to bring the
left face clockwise now we can realign
the center's and we don't have to worry
about splitting these two up okay so now
we have two newly matched pairs what I'm
going to do now is look again for pieces
which we can match up so here I see I
have a outer orange white edge piece and
here I have a middle orange white edge
piece the ones that I like to start with
first are the white edge pieces because
they're the easiest to spot in my
opinion so this one is in the middle
layer and has white on the front this
one is in the outer or if you turn it
this way it's in the inside up layer and
it has orange so all I have to do is
bring this piece down so that they're on
the same face like that now this middle
edge piece is on the middle layer so I
have to make sure that here is where an
unmatched pair is so now I bring this
piece over to that piece it's on the
right side so I bring the right face
clockwise or up bring the top face
towards me so now this newly Maps pair
is here and then I bring the right face
back down and now I could realign the
center's okay you just keep on doing
that the same thing over and over again
so if you look around the cube here I
have a green white piece and here I have
a another green white piece which is
outer
this one's on the middle layer if I get
this one down here it will be on the
inside down layer but all we have to do
is flip the cube over in order to do
that so I put it here and now I could
bring it to this face now you'll see
this one is here and this one's here so
you just turn the cube over and now
you'll see that this one's on the inside
up and this one's on the middle make
sure that you have an unmatched pair
here these two pieces are not matched up
don't get confused because these two
pieces are matched up because these are
the two that are going to split so I
bring this piece over to that piece it's
on the right side so I bring the right
face clockwise bring the top towards me
so now you have to see this unmatched
pair here I'm sorry the newly matched
pair should be here and then you bring
the right face counterclockwise or back
down and now you can realign the
center's and as you'll see you're not
going to break up that and by doing that
we actually brought this piece in I
didn't even mean to do that but now you
have a completed Treach here okay so
look around the cubes still and here I
have a orange green outer edge piece and
here is another orange green piece which
is in the middle layer there they're
correctly lined up in order to match
them so you just make sure that you have
an unmatched pair here which we do so I
bring this piece over to that piece
bring it up out of the way by bringing
it towards us and then bring the left
face back down and then realign the
center's okay so because they have time
constraints I'm not going to be able to
going I'm not going to be able to go
through pairing every single edge piece
so now that you know the method for
pairing the edges I would like you to
try to get as many of those edge pairs
as possible making sure that you don't
break up any of the newly matched pairs
I'm now going to go over what happens
when you're close to finishing the edges
and you start to run out of those
unmatched pairs all right so if we look
around the cube you'll notice that we
have at least one matched pair at each
tread location now we must be careful
that we don't break up any of those
newly matched edge pairs when matching
the remaining edges I'm going to show
you how to position the unmatched pairs
to complete edge pairing since you now
know the method I'm going to go a little
bit faster
okay so I have a orange white piece
which I can match up with these but they
have to be opposite so I bring this one
down put that over there bring it back I
have an unmatched pair directly in front
of the middle edge piece so I can match
it up on the left side so I bring it up
bring it towards me so it's now in front
and then bring the left face back down
now I could realign the center's so now
I keep looking around the cube and I
have these pieces already matched up
already set to be matched so all I have
to do is get an unmatched pair in this
spot so I could use this one right here
so I turn it until it's there now I can
match this piece up with the middle
piece it's on the left side now so I
bring it up and bring the newly matched
pair in front then I bring the left side
back down and then I rely on the
center's alright so now if I look around
the cube I can match this pair up with
this piece so I get it up to the same
face now I see I do have an unmatched
pair here so what I do I match it up
same thing bring the right face up and
bring that newly matched pair towards it
now I bring the right face back down and
realign the center's keep looking around
the cube I actually have these already
set to be matched however I don't have
an unmatched pair here so I get I can
use this one all I do is twist it until
it's in that spot now I could pair this
piece up with that piece it's on the
left side so I bring it up and bring it
towards me then I bring the left side
back down and realign the center's keep
looking around the cube I could pair
this piece with that piece so I get it
so that I can be paired I don't have an
unmatched pair here that I can use so
what I could do I could use this one so
I twist it so now i pair it up I have an
unmatched pair here so I pair it
bring it up and in front and then bring
the left side back down now I could
realign the centers okay now I can get
these paired with this piece so I can
bring this piece down get that over
there and then bring it back I don't
have an unmatched pair in that spot so
what I could do is I could use this on
matched pair here so all I have to do is
rotate this around now when I pair this
up I can use this unmatched pair here so
I pair it on the left side I bring it up
and towards it then I bring it back down
and realign the center's okay so now if
I look at the cube I see that I have two
pairs left so even if I try to align
them I'm not going to be able to match
them up this is because I have a parity
error so there are no more unmatched
pairs which I can use I just have these
two treasures left so even if I went
like that I can't match it up and if I
went like that it's not going to do any
good so this is a parity error which I
will now go over in the next part how to
solve at this point you should have all
of the treasures completely solved and
two of them are probably left that you
have to fix because of parity